Do you have doctors, functionally, doctors, or
naturopaths that you would recommend in a soda if I have other health issues?
I would like to go to someone familiar with your work.
No, just use us. So if you have other things, other
comorbidities just call and make an appointment with me and we'll go over that. So we could go over anything you want to go over.
So just use you are already using me. I already know your history.
Just communicate with me and that goes with your family members too. I have a daughter who's got, you know, you know, menstrual issues or something.
That's fine. Just make an appointment with me with her. Another case reviewed. We'll go over it and discuss different therapies and things.
Remember, all the courses are open to you too. So you should have access to all the courses.
And the reason why I created those courses is so that I could refer people to something on that course.
I do that often. Oh, I'm having all these memory issues of county thinking and stuff and I can refer them to a video on the course or they're having issues with their thyroid.
We're going to refer you to the autoimmune course. The last section of the autoimmune course is all about the thyroid.
So if I can't help you if it's something beyond my school, then we can try to find somebody that could help you with something that you need help with.
So there is there is a functional that I wouldn't call them functional MDs, but they're very
in Minnesota. There's a kingdom health that we refer people to who need a prescription for something because they are very friendly to our work.
They refer us a lot of patients actually, but, you know, you only need to go there if you need to get something that we can't provide like a medical prescription.
Let's say a person has strepthrone or something and they do want to get an antibiotic. Well, then we'll send them over there.
But use us, call and schedule an appointment with me. I'll go over all sorts of non-cancer things with you as well.